[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راوي القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
الجوانبه
من احتجاز موسكو لصحفي وولد
وتدعو الامريكيين لمغادره روسيا فورا
الجيش السوداني يقرر عدم التوقيع على
الاتفاق اذا لم يتم التفاهم حول سنوات دمج
الدعم السريع
وزاره الصحه العمانيه تدعو الى عدم السفر
لتنزانيا وغينيا الاستوائيه بسبب تفشي
فيروس ماربورج
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
تستعد لحظر تيك توك الكامل في امريكا
بلمن ثمانيه الانتشار سريع للغايه وتيك
توك يساعد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم زمن الجواسيس عاد واليوم شبيه
بالبارحه نحن نعيش اليوم فتره زمنيه
مماثله لما كانت عليه الامور خلال الحرب
البارده بين الاتحاد السوفيتي والولايات
المتحده اقتباس من كتاب البحث عن جاسوس
الكي جي بي في المناصب العليا في
المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه لروبرت باير
وهو ضابط سابق بوكاله المخابرات المركزيه
تتكرر بين حين لاخر عمليات القبض على
جواسيس بين البلدين لكن هناك قصص كبيره
ففي عام 2019 قلل الكريم من شان قصه كبيره
تقارير اعلاميه امريكيه عن جاسوس كان يعمل
في الرئاسه الروسيه وصفتها موسكو وقتها
بانها محض خيال رغم الاعتراف بان الشخص
المشار اليه عمل في الكرامل موسكو كانت
على تنفيذ المخابرات الامريكيه لعمليه عام
2017 لتهريب اكبر مصدر سري للمعلومات من
داخل روسيا ظل يمد واشنطن بمعلومات سريه
على مدى عقود الان ونحن في عام 2023 تغير
الامر لم يقلل الكريم من قصه اخرى وان بدت
اقل خطرا ايفان قرش كوفيتش او قرش كوفيتشا
مراسل صحيفه
الامريكيه اعتقلت موسكو اليوم بتهمه
التجسس لصالح واشنطن الكريم المشهود
هذا من اختصاص جهاز الامن الفيدرالي لقد
اصدروا بيانا وليس لدينا ما نضيفه هنا
الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكنني قوله هو انه تم
القبض عليه بالجرم المشهور
في الاثناء قررت محكمه روسيه احتجاز مراسل
بو
لس
وخلال محاكمته اكد مراسل جونل انه غير
مذنب في الاتهامات اتهامات التجسس
المواجهه اليه فيما قال محامي انه منع من
دخول قاعه المحكمه والاطلاع على الاتهامات
وفي اول رد فعل امريكيين رسميا على احتجاز
الصحفي الامريكي ايفان جرش كوفيتش في
روسيا بتهمه التجسس دعا البيت الابيض
المواطنين الامريكيين الى مغادره روسيا
فورا وعدم السفر اليها واوضح البيت الابيض
ان اداره بايدن تواصلت مع عائله مراسل
صحيفه وكذلك الحكومه الروسيه واضاف ان
اداره بايدن تحدثت مع المسؤولين في
الصحيفه حول ظروف احتجاز الصحفي الامريكيه
بدوره دانه وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني
بلينكن احتجاز الصحفي وما وصفه بمحاولات
الكريملين المستمره لقمع الصحفيين
ومعاقبتهم على حد قوله
من جهه عقالات روسيا انها ستسمح للولايات
المتحده بالوصول القنصلي الى مراسل صحيفه
وسطي جونل المعتقل لديها بتهمه التجسس في
الوقت المناسب واوضحت المتحدثه باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخرفه ان الجانب
الامريكي طلب من خلال القنوات
الدبلوماسيه الوصول للقنصلي للمواطن
الامريكي الذي تم اعتقاله
وكان الاتحاد الاوروبي منذ قليل صرح بان
السلطات الروسيه تكشف مجددا عن ازدراء
حريات الاعلام
ودانت اعتقال روسيا لمراسل
وفي سابقه منذ الحرب البارده بات اول
مراسل لوسيله امريكيه يتم اعتقاله بتهمه
التجسس في رو
سيا تصعيد اخر على جبهه اخرى بين موسكو
واشنطن جهاز الامن الاتحادي الروسي يعتقل
صحفيا امريكيا من اصل روسي يعمل مراسلا
لصحيفه وولد جورنال الامريكيه اما التهمه
فهي الاشتباه في قيامه بالتجسس لمصلحه
واشنطن الامن الروسي قال ان ايفان
جريشكوفيتش كان مكلفا من امريكا بجمع
معلومات عن انشطه احدى المؤسسات الدفاعيه
غير ان بيان جهاز الامن الروسي لم يقدم
دليلا على الاتهامات
صحيفه وولز جون نفت ما وصفتها بالمزاعم
الروسيه الموجهه لمراسلها واكدت انها تسعى
لاطلاق سراحه فورا
لكن الخارجيه الروسيه التي تعترف
بجرشكوفيتش مراسلا معتمدا في روسيا قالت
انما كان يفعله لا علاقه له بالصحافه
الكريم من جانبه قال ايضا ان مراسل وولد
جورنال ضبط متلبسا بالتجسس وملفه بيد
الامن الفيدرالي
موسكو استبعدت اي تبادل لجيرش كوفيتش مع
واشنطن واكدت ان ذلك ليس على جدول اعمالها
ولن يحدث ذلك قبل محاكمته جرش كوفيتش اول
صحفي امريكي يقبض عليه في روسيا بتهمه
التجسس منذ الحرب البارده وابرز شخصيه
امريكيه تعتقلها روسيا بعد نجمه كره السله
العام الماضي حيث قبض عليها في مطار موسكو
وبحوزتها زيت الحشيش اطلق سراحها في صفقه
لتبادل السجناء بين البلدين في ديسمبر
الماضي
الينا من واشنطن مديره مكتب العربيه
ومن موسكو كاتيا تعمي ايضا مراسله العربيه
اهلا بكنا يعني ابدا معك ناديه موسكو تقول
بانه من السابق لاوانه الان الحديث عن
تبادل
للاسرى بين موسكو واشنطن كيف يمكن للعاصمه
الامريكيه ان ترد على هذا الاعتقال
اولا البيت الابيض راويه يعتبر بان هذا
الاتهام وهذا الاعتقال هو باطل وبانه غير
مقبول حسب بيان البيت الابيض وعلى السلطات
في موسكو اطلاق سراح الصحفي الذي يعمل
لصحيفه وولز وتقول بانه هو معتمد لديه
بطاقه صحافه يعمل فيها لماذا الان اكتشفت
موسكو بانه يقوم بعمليه التجسس بين قوسين
لانه الاداره لا تعتبر بانه
جاسوس طبعا وبانه يعمل لحساب اي من جهه
استخباريه وليس فقط البيت الابيض لكن ايضا
الكونجرس اعضاء في الكونغرس قالوا بان ما
تقوم به موسكو هو متوقع ضمن هذه الخطط
التي رايناها مؤخرا منذ بدايه الحرف في
اوكرانيا وهي عمليه اختطاف لمواطنين
امريكيين حسب توصيف بعض اعضاء الكونغرس
وربما عمليه اختطافهم كرهائن مقابل
مقايضتهم مع مواطنين روز في الولايات
المتحده وبالتالي لا نتحدث الان على اي
مقايضه على الاطلاق نتحدث عن اتصال مباشر
بين وزاره الخارجيه والقنصليه في موسكو في
محاوله معرفه الاتهامات وجهت الى وايضا
الاتصال بعائلته وبالتالي واشنطن ترى بان
هذه الاتهامات مسيسه وهي تاتي ضمن حاله
التوتر التي تعيشها موسكو واشنطن منذ
بدايه الحرف في اوكرانيا
ما الحجج التي تقدمها موسكو لاعتقال هذا
الصحه في الامريكي بمعنى هل كان هناك
خلفيه هل تم تحذيره بوقت سابق ولم يلتزم
بما وجه اليه مثلا
مرحبا حقيقه لم يتم الكشف عن هذه التفاصيل
ولكن جهاز الامن الفيدرالي كان قد تحدث ان
الصحفي الامريكي كان يعمل في مدينه
وكان يجمع معلومات حول مجمع صناعي عسكري
وهذا ما يعتبر ضمن القانون الروسي انه
مخالف للقانون ويعتبر
تسريب معلومات وتجسس طبعا على الاسرار
الدوله لذلك وجهت اليه تهمه التجسس لصالح
الحكومه الامريكيه تحت غطاء الصحافه كما
تحدثت اليوم المتحدثه الرسميه باسم
الخارجيه طبعا ان هناك يوجد اثباتات على
تورطه بهذه العمليه ولكنه ايضا لم يتم
الكشف حتى الان عن تفاصيل كل كل العمليه
الاعتقال لان الصحفي تم اعتقاله هو اخذه
مباشره الى المحكمه الجلسه كانت مغلقه حتى
ان الصحفي منع محاميه الخاص من الدخول هذه
الجلسه او كما تحدث بعض الخبراء بسبب طبعا
حساسيه المواضيع التي سيتم مناقشتها خلال
جلسه المحكمه وصدر حكم اعتقاله لمده شهرين
طبعا منذ قليل كانت الخارجيه تحدثت ان سمح
لي الدخول القنصلي الامريكي الى السجين
سمح بالوصول الى السجين من قبل القنصليه
الامريكيه هنا في موسكو راويه نعم
كاتيا وايضا ناديه ارجو التفضل منكما
بالبقاء معي لنتعرف ايضا مع المشاهدين على
بعض المعلومات حول الصحفي الذي اعتقلته
روسيا
ايفان جيرش كوفيتش صحفي امريكي روسي
الاصلي يتقن اللغه الروسيه يبلغ من العمر
31 عاما ووالداهم قيمان في الولايات
المتحده منذ 1979
مراسل يغطي روسيا واوكرانيا لدى صحيفه
وولد جورنال الامريكيه كان مراسلا لوكاله
فرانسبريس في موسكو قبل 2022
عمل كصحفيا في صحيفه موسكو تايمز الصادره
بالانجليزيه في 2017 اول مراسل بوسيله
اعلام امريكيه يعتقل بتهمه التجسس في
روسيا منذ الحرب البارده اعتقل في مدينه
كاترينبورج بجبالاورال متورط في جمع
معلومات سريه بحسب وكاله الاستخبارات
الروسيه قررت محكمه روسيه حجزه لمده شهرين
على ذمه التحقيق بتهمه التجسس
عوده اليك ناديه وايضا كاتيا ناديه يعني
الكرام ننظر الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
من اي عمل انتقاميه يستهدف وسائل اعلام
روسيه موجوده على الاراضي الامريكيه ومن
هنا اسالك عن هذه الوسائل الاعلام الروسيه
العامله وعن وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه كيف
نظرت الى عمليه التوقيف هذه
اولا الاداره الامريكيه تقول بانها لن
تجري عمليه انتقام اذا اردت بطرد صحفيين
لانه بالنهايه تعتبر روسيا بانها تقمع
الصحفيين روسيا بالنسبه حتى للصحفيين
المحليين ترى واشنطن بانه لا يوجد هناك
صحافه مستقله او حره هي تقوم باعتقالهم
باسكات اصواتهم وبالتالي واشنطن تعتبر بان
الديمقراطيه ترتكز بدرجه اساسيه على حريه
الصحافه ومن هنا لن تقوم بطرد اي صحفي
روسيس وكان يعمل مع وكاله تاس او مع رشه
توداي او روسيا اليوم او غيرها من
الولايات المتحده هي ترى بان هذا الاجراء
اعتقال ايفان هو اجراء تعسفي بالدرجه
الاولى وهو مسيز وايضا روسيا في بدايه هذه
الحرب على اوكرانيا كانت تعتقل وتجرم
الصحفيين عندما يستخدمون كلمه او عباره
الهجوم الروسي على اوكرانيا
تقول بانه يجب استخدام العمليات العسكريه
فقط وهذا ادى الى ربما سحب معظم الصحفيين
الامريكيين والغربيين الذين كانوا يعملوا
في روسيا طبعا وجود ايضا كما ذكرت تقرير
قبل قليل بانه من اصول الروسيه بانه عائله
هاجرت الى الولايات المتحده يتحدث الروسيه
بطلاقه ويعمل مع صحيفه معروفه جدا وهي
بالتالي الاداره تقول بانه اعتقاله هو
مسيس بالدرجه الاولى بانه لا علاقه له
بعمليه تجسس هي محاوله ضمن ما تسميها
بالالاعيب الروسيه باعتقال المواطنين
الامريكيين التي حضرت ايضا وزاره الخارجيه
حضرتهم من الذهاب الى موسكو لانها لا تريد
ان تتكرس سيناريوهات سابقه كما رايناها
معا لعبه كره السله الشهيره التي اضطرت
اداره بايدن ان تقايدها مع تاجر سلاح روسي
كان يسمى بتاجر الموت وبالتالي الان نتحدث
عن توتر وتصعيد جديد بين موس ولا احد
يتحدث عن المقايضه على الاقل حتى الان نعم
يعني بموضوع المقيده الجانب الرسمي كما
تقول ناديه من المبكر الحديث عنه
الكريملين ايضا والجانب الروسي قال من
المبكر الحديث عنه ولكن بهكذا حالات كيف
يتم التعامل مع حالات التوقيف هل يعني
المحاكمات تاخذ وقتا ام يتم الحكم بشكل
نهائي لانه الان القضيه هي في طور التحقيق
نعم بالفعل من خلال كل ما الاعتقالات التي
حدثت سابقا واخرها كانت طبعا اللعب
الامريكيه لعبه السله كانت قد اعتقلت ثم
كانت هناك جلسات متتاليه جلسات محاكمه
متتاليه وبالتالي فيما بعد تم الحكم عليها
ونقلها فيما بعد ايضا الى السجن لقضاء مده
الحكم وهذا بالتاكيد سيكون ايضا بالنسبه
للصحفي الامريكي ايضا ولكن حتى الان كما
ذكرت راويه لا يوجد اي تفاصيل عن الجلسات
اللاحقه التي ستعقد من قبل المحكمه وعن
فيما اذا كان هناك طبعا امكانيه دخول
المحامي الخاص
للصحفي هذه المعلومات سيتم طبعا الكشف
عنها في الايام اللاحقه راويه نعم شكرا
جزيلا لكنا ناديه البلباسي مديره مكتب
العربيه في واشنطن وايضا كاتيا طعمه من
موسكو
في المقابل كشف تقرير للمعهد الملكي
للخدمات المتحده في بريطانيا ان روسيا
جندت شبكه عملاء سريين في اوكرانيا قبل
بدء الحرب ولا تزال تعمل حتى الان
شبكه من العملاء السريين نشرتهم روسيا في
اوكرانيا قبل الحرب هذه الشبكه ما تزال
تعمل حتى اليوم وتشكل تدفقا ثابتا من
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه كيف اعتقلت الاف
الاشخاص منذ بدايه الحرب بتهمه التعاون مع
روسيا وفقا لتقرير للمعهد الملكي للخدمات
المتحده موسكو اسست شبكات وجندت كثيرين
عبر الخداع فبينما يعتقد البعض من هؤلاء
المجندين الاوكرانيين في مناطق النزاع
بانهم يخدمون بلدهم افعالهم تعود بالنفع
لروسيا بغير قصد
الدبابات غربيه الصنع وصلت دفعات منها
لاوكرانيا لكن استخدامها في بدايه الهجوم
المضاد غير محتمل بحسب تقرير النيوزك قبل
يومين اعلنت المانيا ان اوكرانيا استلمت
18 دبابات دبابات اثنين الى جانب الذخيره
وقطع الغيار ومركبتين انقاذ مدرعتين برلين
اضافت انه بنهايه العام الحالي ستكون
ثمانون دبابه اخرى من طرز اقدم متاحه
للاستعمال في اوكرانيا لكن نقلت عن خبراء
عسكريين قولهم ان فعاليه الدبابات تعتمد
على عده عوامل في ساحه المعركه من بينها
الطقس الطقس السيء لا يناسب هذه الدبابات
لثقل وزنها ما قد يجعلها تعلق في الوحل
الامر سيؤدي لجعل حركتها على طرق غير
ممهده امرا صعبا للغايه انتظار تحسن
الظروف الجويه سيمنح الجيش الاوكراني فرصه
الدبابات في اي موقع وربما ايضا تدريب
المزيد من الجنود عليها وبحسب المحللين قد
تختار اوكرانيا عدم استعمال دبابات لوبارد
وتشالنجر وان تحاول اولا اختراق الخطوط
الروسيه على العكس من هذا الراي قال
القائد السابق القوات الامريكيه في اوروبا
بن هاتجز ان تفوق الدبابات الغربيه على
نظيرتها الروسيه ستعطي اوكرانيا افضليه
خلال الهجوم المضل واعتبر المسؤول السابق
ان الدبابات هذه يمكنها ان تشكل حاجزا
مصفحا يصعب اجتيازه وان تكسر خطوط الدفاع
الروسيه للتقدم في مختلف الجبهات نتحدث
طبعا عن وايضا جزيره القرن
[موسيقى]
وبشان معارك الربيع وقع الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين مرسوما بشان التجنيد
الاجباري للروس في الربيع وحسب المرسوم
يجب على المواطنين الروس الذين تتراوح
اعمارهم بين 18 الى سبعه وعشرين عاما
التقدم للتجنيد في الخدمه العسكريه بدايه
من ابريل وهو مرسوم يستهدف 147 الف شخص
ماكرون يتحدى الفرنسيين مره اخرى
الاحتجاجات لن توقف قانون التقاعد تابعونا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد افادت مصادر للعربيه ان
الجيش السوداني قرر عدم المشاركه في
التوقيع على الاتفاق السياسي المقرر السبت
المقبل ما لم يتم الارتفاع على سنوات دمج
الدعم السريع داخل الجيش التي وضع لها
الجيش مدى زماني قدره 36 شهرا ياتي ذلك في
وقت لم تتوج ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
الاتفاق على اي تواقيت زمنيه حول مساله
دمج قوات الدعم السريع داخل الجيش
السوداني
ومن الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك معنا سالم هل سيتم
التوقيع على بيان الاتفاق ام لا هذا هو
السؤال الاكبر
اهلاويه بدايه لم تتضح الصوره بعد لكن
الامر معقد بكل تاكيد خاصه ان المصادر
اكدت انه لن يكون هنالك توقيع لان الجيش
شرهن هذا التوقيع
بان يتم الاتفاق على التوصيات من ورشه
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري ويتم اعتماد هذه
التوصيات لتضمن ضمن الاتفاق النهائي حتى
الان اللجنه الفنيه لم تفرق من صياغه هذه
التوصيات بوجود الخلاف والبون الشاسع ما
بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش في مساله
التواقيت الزمنيه من ناحيه هذا ما يراه
الجيش السوداني وبالناحيه الاخرى قوات
الدعم السريع ما ترى انه اصلاح للمؤسسه
العسكريه وانه يجب الالتزام بهذا الامر
فهنا البون شاسع لم يتم لم تفرغ اللجان
الفنيه حتى الان والوقت ضيق تماما بقي يوم
واحد هو يوم الجمعه يوم غد والتوقيع يفترض
ان يكون السبت في المقابل هو الموقع
الاتفاق الايطالي اكد الناطق الرسمي باسم
العمليه السياسيه خالد عمر يوسف بانه لم
يتم التاجيل حتى اللحظه الان
اجتماع للحريه والتغيير او عفوا القوى
الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي مدنيين
وعسكريين في القصر الجمهوري ربما ينتج عن
هذا الاجتماع اما تعديل
للجدوله الزمنيه او تاكيد ان الاتفاق او
ان التوقيع سيكون يوم السبت
يا سالم الهاشمي ونذهب لنستمع لما قاله
رئيس دائره الاعلام في حزب الامه القومي
السوداني والقيادي في قوى الحريه والتغيير
مصباح احمد الذي اكد انه لا يوجد اي تاجيل
حتى الان لتوقيع الاتفاق السياسي النهائي
في الاولي من ابريل
حتى الان ليس هنالك تاجيل
توقيعه الاتفاق النهائي في الاول من ابريل
حتى هذه اللحظه بالامس اجتماع الامس اكد
على على الالتزام كل الاطراف
بالمضيب العمليه السياسيه الى نهايتها
والالتزام بالمواقيت الزمنيه التي اتفق
عليها في 15 مارس للمنصرين سالم من جديد
غير الطواقيد الزمنيه ما العقبات او
الخلافات المعلن عنها بورشه الاصلاح
الامني والعسكري التي تجري اجتماعات مكثفه
في الايام الاخيره
نعم بكل تاكيد ورشه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري التي امتدت لاربعه ايام هذه
الورشه كانت مغلقه كل جلساتها عدا الجلسه
الافتتاحيه والختاميه لكن ما وصلنا من
انباء ان الخلافات تطال مسائل اخرى متعلقه
بالدعم السريع كذلك ومتعلقه بامور يطالب
بها الدعم السريع في مطالبات باصلاح الجيش
السوداني وايضا مطالبات ان لا يكون
التقسيم المناطق والعداله بين المناطق في
التمثيل داخل الجيش كل هذه المسائل هناك
تحفظات من قيادات الدعم السريعه على هذا
الامر في المقابل الجيش السوداني يرى انه
الدعم السريعي يجب ان يدمج في سنتين هذا
ما يتم تداوله بشكل كبير بان يتم الدمج في
سنتين والدعم السريع يرى ان هذه فتره
قصيره جدا لا تفي بالالتزامات الاخرى في
المقابل من اصلاح الجيش السوداني
والمضي في عمليه الاصلاح بشكل كامل
الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي
[موسيقى]
وصل قائد فيلق القدس في الحرس الثوري
الايراني اسماعيل قائني الى العراق وافادت
وسائل الاعلام عراقيه ان قراني سيعقد
لقاءات مع مسؤولين عراقيين كما شارك في
جنازه رجل الدين محمد صادق الحكيم في
النجف
[موسيقى]
اوضحت وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه ان وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار بن خفير
سيطلب من الحكومه يوم الاحد القادم
الموافقه على مشروع قرار خاص بانشاء حرس
وطني تحت مسؤوليه الوزاره وتضم القوه
الفيجنديه يخدعون لبن خفير مباشره وفقا
لاقتراح نشر يوم امس المشروع القرار على
استخدام الحرس الوطني الاسرائيلي كقوه
خاصه ومدربه للتعامل مع سيناريوهات
الطوارئ المختلفه والجريمه القوميه
ومكافحه الارهاب واستعاده الحكم عند
الحاجه
وزير اخر يثير ازمه في حكومه نتنياهو وهو
مهندس التعديلات القضائيه وزير العدل يا
ريف ليفين الذي تعهد ببذل جهد كبير لضمان
تمرير التشريع خلال الجلسه الصيفيه
المقبله للكنيست وزير العدل اشار الى
تنظيم تظاهرات في جميع انحاء اسرائيل
لاظهار ما تريده غالبيه الجمهور وردا على
ذلك دعا زعيم المعارضه رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو دعاه الى اعلان ان تصريحات لفين
لا تعكس وجهه نظره
[موسيقى]
روسيا الصين ودول اخرى فتحت الناره على
الدولار الامريكي حرب اقتصاديه تسعى الى
كسر هيمنه الدولار والبحث عن بدائل له في
التبادلات التجاريه من خلال العملات
المحليه كروبل الروسي واليوان الصيني
تندلعوا حروب عملات من وقت لاخر يكون
الطرف المحارب فيها هو الدولار هو اطراف
القتال متعدده اخرها الصين والبرازيل بعد
اعلانهما تخليهما عن الدولار الامريكي
اتفاق يتيح للصين ثاني عملاق تجاري واكبر
منافس للهيمنه الاقتصاديه الامريكيه
والبرازيل اكبر اقتصاد في امريكا
اللاتينيه والشركه التجاريه الاكبر للصين
اجراء صفقاتهما التجاريه الهائله مباشره
واستبدالها بالعمله المحليه
فالتبادل التجاري بينهما قدر ب150 مليار
دولار في العام الماضي فقط
على الجانب الاخر حرب اقتصاديه تدور راحها
في ساحه اخرى هي روسيا والمحارب فيها هو
الدولار الامريكي ايضا
موسكو لم تتخذ فقط من اوكرانيا ساحه حرب
لها بل بالتوازي استخدمت اسواق العالم ارض
حرب اخرى سلاح روسيا فيها ضد امريكا ليس
عسكريا بل تجاري
تجاريا اتخذت موسكو سلاح الروبل للحد من
استخدام الدولار في معاملاتها الدوليه حتى
الطاقه كانت احد اسلحه روسيا الفعاله في
مارس الماضي اصدرت موسكو مرسوما يقضي ببيع
الغاز والنفط للدول غير الصديقه حصرا
بالروبل
كما انها عززت من علاقاتها الخارجيه خاصه
مع الصين الصديق التاريخي لها تجمعهما
مساء لم تعد خفيه تاسيس نظام دولي جديد لا
يعتمد على الدولار كعمله رئيسيه في
التبادلات التجاريه والماليه اما الهند
الشريك الوطيد لروسيا فسبق ان اعلنت العام
الماضي عن اتفاق ثنائي باستخدام عملتيهما
المحليتين في التبادل التجاري بينهما
الخزانه الامريكيه ترى ان كسر هيمنه
الدولار امر صعب جدا فيما اخرون يحذرون من
تداعياته
فمحاولات اضعاف الدولار قد تعني نظاما
نقديا اكثر تشتتا ومجاميع تجاريه منفصله
بتكتلات عملات صغيره روان حمزه العربيه
ومن اثنى ينظم الينا عبر سكايب الدكتور
عبد اللطيف درويش استاذ العلاقات استاذه
الاقتصاد واداره الازمات بجامعه اهلا بك
استاذ عبد اللطيف يعني يبدو ان خصوم
الولايات المتحده يفكون ارتباطهم بالدولار
ما تداعيات ذلك فعليا على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وعلى الاقتصاد العالمي
تحياتي لكم المشاهدين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بسبب كون ان الدولار عمله صعبه
تستعمل في تبادلات تجاريه
سيكون لديها حصه من اي تعامل تجاري على
الكره الارضيه الان حين نتحدث عن دوله
تشمل الصين دول تشمل الصين
روسيا الهند
ودول اخرى نحن نتحدث تقريبا عن ثلاثه
مليار من سكان الكره الارضيه فقط هذه
الدول وهذه المجموعه الكتله البشريه
الهائله نحن نتحدث انه حتى في التعاملات
التجاريه فيما بينهم سيتم حرم الولايات
المتحده الامريكان من التعامل بالدولار
والدولار القيمه الاساسيه له ليست سوى
التعاملات التجاريه يعني عباره عن حاله
اعطاء حاله وهم لقيمه فقط لاقناع الناس
بانها عمله صعبه فبالتالي الان ستخسر
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه فقط من على
الاقل من التعاملات الداخليه بهذه الدول
نعطي مثلا من المنطقه العربيه
التبادلات التجاريه فقط تشتري مصر من
روسيا واوكرانيا 90% من القمع من هذه
الدول من اوكرانيا وروسيا فبالتالي ستحرم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بان يكون لها
حصه حاولت العديد من الدول في الماضي ان
تتبنى الدولار ان تخرج من اطار الدولار
ودفعت الثمن كالعراق وكوبا في عهد كاسترو
ولكن الدول الان التي تقارع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وتسعى لان تحصل على ان
تكون عملتها في الصداره وتستعمل دول كبرى
يصعب على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
معاقباتها فبالتالي ايضا سيضعف قدره
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي اخذت من
نفسها انها هي الحاكم الذي يعاقب هذه
الدوله ويعاقب تلك الدوله فبالتالي الانان
المتحده الامريكي يضعف اقتصاديا وسياسيا
بس بب هذا الموضوع ابقى معي يا استاذ عبد
اللطيف لانه هناك تقرير للمجلس الاطلسي في
واشنطن هذا التقرير اشاره الى المخاطر
التي تحدثنا عنها واحتماليه تقليص بعض
الدول الاعتمادها على الدولار الامريكي
نتابع تفاصيله
المجلس الاطلسي في واشنطن اصدر تقريرا
بعنوان اهم 23 خطرا وفرصه للعام 2023
التقرير تحدث عن احتمال ابتعاد عده دول
منها حلفاء وخصوم للولايات المتحده عن
الدولار تقليص هذه الدول اعتمادها على
الدولار سيكون بشكل اسرع مما كان متوقعا
بحسب التقرير
العقوبات غير المسبوقه على روسيا بسبب حرب
اوكرانيا زادت احتماليه الابتعاد السريع
عن الدولار عمليا ما تزال مزايا الدولار
متجذره بعمق في النظام المالي العالمي لكن
التحول يحدث تدريجيا وحصه الدولار من
احتياطيات النقد الاجنبي اخده في الانخفاض
عده دول بدات تستثمر في التقنيات مثل
العملات الرقميه لتقليل الاعتماد على
الدولار منها الصين والهند واندونيسيا
وماليزيا وجنوب افريقيا
جديد الدكتور عبد اللطيف درويش استاذه
الاقتصاد واداره الازمات بجامعه ينضم
الينا استاذ عبد اللطيف يعني هل يختلف فك
الارتباط مع الدولار الامريكي بين الدول
الناميه والدول الغنيه
طبعا الدول
الناميه ستكون ايضا بمصلحتها ان يكون هذا
التعامل لان صعوبه الحصول على الدولار
اريد ان اعطيكم مثل قامت الصين بمسامحه
قبل بعض الدول الافريقيه
بدينونها مقابل ان تتبنى هذه الدول العمله
الصينيه كعمله وطنيه لانه العديد من دول
افريقيا انهارت عملاتها الوطنيه فبالتالي
هذا الجزء ايضا من
حصول الصين على اسواق حتى فليس اسواق
السلع وانما ايضا سوق المال التي تدخل له
رويدا رويدا الدول حين اتحدث عن دول
العملاقه في موضوع الطاقه مثل السعوديه
وروسيا التي الان روسيا تتعامل بموضوع
الروبل
وايضا من خلال الاتفاقيه السعوديه الصينيه
بالعملات الوطنيه الولايات المتحده ستخسر
هناك طبعا الولايات المتحده الصراع الذي
يحصل الان هو الحرب البارده سابقا لناتي
بمثل قبل ذلك هي كانت حرب اقتصاديه الان
الغرب يصارع ويقاتل في افريقيا وهنا وهناك
والولايات المتحده لانهم خسروا الاسواق
الان ننتقل الى الاسواق الماليه واعتقد ان
الدول يجب عليها ان تتعلم من خلال الطرق
التي تم التعامل معها مع روسيا في عقوبات
الاقتصاديه
واخراجا من نظام سويفت وبالتالي ستظهر في
المنطقه في الفتره القادمه مؤسسات ماليه
موازيه للعية صندوق النقد الدولي والبنك
الدولي وستظهر ايضا مؤسسات ماليه للاقراض
على مستوى اقليمي تنافس ايضا لتاخذ ايضا
تغسل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مؤسسات
الاقراض التي ليست سواء مؤسسات تاثير
سياسي كما هي كثير اقتصادي وبالتالي ايضا
الدول ستقارع الولايات المتحده طبعا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لن تخرج من
السوق بس هوله ستكون ولاده العالم الجديد
والقطق اقطاب الجديده الاقتصاديه لن تكون
سهله
لانه هناك تجذر للدولار الامريكي
بالاقتصاد والنظام المالي العالمي شكرا
جزيلا لك الدكتور عبد اللطيف درويش استاذ
الاقتصاد واداره الازمات بجامعه
لمساعدتها في الازمه مع واشنطن تيك توك
تعين مستشارا سابقا لاوباما تابعونا بعد
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد دعت وزاره الصحه
العمانيه المواطنين الى عدم السفر الى
تنزانيا وغينيا الاستوائيه الى للضروره
القصوى بسبب تفشي فيروس ماربورغ في
البلدين وقالت وزاره الصحه العمانيه انها
تراقب وتفشي المرض في البلدين كونه شديد
العدوى وتصل نسبه الوفيات فيه من 60% الى
80%
ومن براج تنضم الينا الدكتوره منى
الاستشاريه الامراض الجرثوميه والفيروسيه
في المستشفى الجامعي في براج اهلا بك
دكتوره منى يعني نحن ما لحقنا خلصنا من
كورونا الان هنالك فيروس جديد وليس بجديد
ولكن تفشي الان بهذه المناطق
بغنيه الاستوائيه فعليا كم يجب ان نقلق
وحدثينا عن مستوى الانتشار الان
مساء الخير استاذه راويه ولك اهلا مشاهدين
بالنسبه مثل ما ذكرتي انه فعلا هو ليس اول
تفشي ولكن اليوم يعني هناك انتشار اكبر
يعني هذا التفشي الاكبر في في هذه السنه
هناك تفشي في العام الماضي
اليوم غينيا الاستوائيه لاول مره بصير في
تفشي فيها 33 حاله مشتبهه منها عشر حالات
مؤكده بالتحاليل المخبريه لكن يعني الى اي
مدى القلق يعني نظمت الصحه العالميه تقول
انه القلق يعني هناك قلق على مستوى الوطني
بهذه الدول
يعني
التفشي او الخطوره معتدله بالنسبه للوضع
الاقليمي بالقرن الافريقيه ومتدلعه طيب
دكتوره بما انه تتحدثين خبرينا اكثر عن
اعراض هذا المرض وهل هناك ملعقات خاصه به
لانه هو ظهر اصلا عام 1967 وبالتالي
المفروض يكون في لقاحات له
نعم للاسف اليوم لحد اليوم معنا اي لقاح
لاله في عده لقاحات يعني تحت التجارب
منظمه الصحه العالميه اليوم تدعو يعني الى
تكثيف الجهود والاستثمارات
حتى انتاج لقاح لهذا المرض الخطير لا يوجد
ايضا دواء نوعي يعني يعني مضاد فيروس له
السبب هو لانه عدد الحالات يعني بشكل عام
ما زال قليلا ولكنه كونه مرض خطير يعني
صار من الحاج حاجه كبيره بالنسبه للدول
الافريقيه خصوصا عدد الحالات يعني المعلن
عنها ربما يكون اقل مما هو في الحقيقه
دائما السبب يكون عندما تكون الامور في
القاره فقيره وفي يعني لا تهتم الدول
الغنيه للاستثمار في هذه الدكتوره دكتوره
هو ما سببه يعني هل النظافه هل وبعدين
اعراضه بماذا يشعر المصاب بهذا الفيروس
خلينا نبدا بالسبب السبب هو فيروس من
الفيروسات الخيطيه من اقرباء الايبولا
وسبب الحمى النفسيه وبالتالي اعراض الحمى
النفسيه المتشابهه مع ايبولا
وينتقل من الحيوان للانسان خصوصا
الخفافيش الفاكهه او حتى النسانيس انواع
من القرود يسبب اعراض لا يمكن تفرقه عن
الابولا من ناحيه ارتفاع الحراره النزوف
الداخليه قيادات اسهالات مدمات
ويمكن طبعا ان في حال لن يسعف المريض او
يعني هو نسبته وفيات عاليه لكن اذا كان في
منشاه صحيه متقدمه رغم عدم وجود علاجنا
وعلاج لكن يحتاج الى سوائل يحتاج الى دعم
لوطائف الاعراض الاعضاء فممكن بهاي الحاله
انه تنخفض الى حد ما نسبه الوفي الدكتور
نحن انتهى وقتنا ولكن سؤال يعني سريع جدا
طريقه الف حص كيف هي
طريقه الفحص هو عن طريق الدم بالبي سي ار
او بالايز اللي هي
الانتجين اللي هو الفحص السريع طبعا اذا
كان متوفر فهذه هي طرق التشخيص
جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات الوافيه
الدكتوره منى كيال استشاريات الامراض
الجرثوميه والفيروسيه في المستشفى الجامعي
في براج
[موسيقى]
اكد الرئيس الفرنسي اما نيويورك وانا
الاحتجاجات في البلاد لن توقف تعديل نظام
التقاعد داعيا النقابات والمحتاجين الى
التهدئه
[موسيقى]
صحيفه
تيك توك عينت مستشارا سابقا لرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق باراك اوباما وذكرت
الصحيفه الامريكيه ان هذه الخطوه للتطبيق
السنيجه لتقديم المشوره لها وراء الكواليس
حيث يحاول تيك توك اقناع السلطات
الامريكيه التي تتهم التطبيق بالتجسس على
هواتف الامريكيين بانه لا يرتبط بالحكومه
الصينيه
في الاثناء وبعد الضغوط التي تعرضت لها
شركه باي دانز المالكه لتطبيق تيك توك
بادرت الاخيره بتطوير تطبيق جديد اطلقته
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تحت مسمى
لمن ايت لمن ثمانيه يمكن ان يكون بديلا
اذا تم حظر تيك توك في كامل امريكا
وصفات طبخ غريبه ومواد تجميل اضافه الى
نصائح الموضه هذا المحتوى الذي يقدمه
تطبيق
الوافد الجديد على منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي الذي اطلقته شركه المالكه
لتطبيق تيك توك في امريكا مؤخرا بعد
اطلاقه في اليابان عام 2020
وقد تم تنزيله سته عشر مليون مره الى الان
مراقبه الاعلان عن هذا التطبيق في امريكا
تزامن مع الضغوط الكبيره التي تعرضت لها
شركه تيك توك في الدول الغربيه فقد تم
استجواب مديرها التنفيذي شاوزي تشو امام
الكونجرس بخصوص مخاوف حول امن وخصوصيه
المعلومات حيث تشك واشنطن ومعها عواصم
غربيه اخرى في ان بكين تستطيع الوصول
لمعلومات مستخدمي تيك توك في امريكا
والغرب وقد تستعملها في جمع معلومات
استخباراتيه تطبيق لمن ايت الذي وصل الى
المركز التاسع بين العشره الاوائل في متجر
التطبيقات الامريكي قد يكون حسب مراقبين
مناوره قامت بها بعد دانس للبقاء في السوق
الامريكي في حال صدور قرار بمنع تيك توك
بشكل نهائي انس نماسي العربيه
[موسيقى]
تواصل وزاره الصحه السعوديه شهودها بتقديم
خدماتها الصحيه والعلاجيه المتميزه لدوقوف
الرحمن وقاصدي البيت الحرام ويعد مستشفى
اجياد للطوارئ بمكه المكرمه المجاوره
للحرم المكي الشريف من ابرز مرافق الصحه
التي خصصتها لتوفير الرعايه الصحيه
والطبيه العلاجيه لهم
ومن هناك من مستشفى اجياد ينضم الينا
سلطان السلم
مراسل العربيه انت سلطان يعني انت الان
بمكه خرجت من المستشفى ولكن حدثنا عن
المعتمرين عن الخدمات الطبيه ايضا التي
تقدم بحول مكه المكرمه
احنا حبينا نغير الصوره في اللحظه الاخيره
صراحه لانه يعطيك الف عافيه
والادوار العلويه والاسطح بالفعل يعني كنا
قبل قليل نتحدث عن الخدمات الصحيه لن
ناخذكم في زاويه مختلفه نريد نوريكم او
نشاهد معكم لقطات علويه
لمنطقه المركزيه والابراج وكذلك
لهذا المعلم هو معلم برج الساعه وهو في
المنطقه المركزيه التي تعتبر هي عباره عن
سلسله من الفنادق العالميه اذ وصلت نسبه
الاشغال فيها الى خمسه وتسعين في المئه
نريد ناخذكم ايضا في لقطات مختلفه ومن
زاويه مختلفه الى صحن المطاف الذي هو
ممتلئ بالكامل وكذلك الى حجر اسماعيل الذي
سمح للمصلين باداء الصلاه في بعد انقطاع
دام لاكثر من اربعه سنوات ممكن زميلنا
محمود ياخذكم في لقطات حيه ومباشره وهي
لقطات علويه الى صحن المطاط والى حجر
اسماعيل لنشاهد عمليه السماح
تحديدا بالصلاه لركعتين فقط ومن ثم
ادخالهم عبر دفعات مختلفه وهذا الامر لم
يكن مسموح به بالسابق نظرا لتداعي عائد
جائحه فيروس كورونا اليوم في هذا الموسم
تم السماح لهم نشاهد امتلاء صحن المطاف
والادوار العلويه وايضا نشاهد تدافع او
نشاهد تحديدا الازدحام او الكل يحرص هنا
من المعتمرين للوصول الى الحجر الاسود
وتقبيله كما يظهر امامكم على الكاميرا
وكذلك حجم المعتمرين الذين يتوافدون
ويريدون الاقتراب من الكعبه لمسها او
التطيب او الوصول اليها والتقاط الصور عند
باب الكعبه تحديدا ولكن هنالك كما نشاهد
اعداد كبيره لكن ايضا هنالك تنظيم اكبر
وتعامل مع هذه الاعداد المليونيه تتحدث عن
اخر احصائيات انه يفيد الى المسجد الحرام
اكثر من مليون و 200 الف مؤتمر ومصلي
يوميا اذا تحدثنا عن التنظيمات
الحشود في الحرم المكي هي تنظيمات مختلفه
اذ تم تخصيص صحن المطاف والادوار العلويه
والاسطح فقط للمعتمرين فيما يتعلق
بعملياتهم في التوسعات السعوديه الثلاثه
وتحديدا وتحديدا التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه
التي تستوعب اكثر من 900 الف مصلي ومع
نهايه المشروع سوف تستقبل مليون و300 الف
مصلي كما تشاهدون اللقطات حيه ومباشره
للكعبه المشرفه والاعداد المليونيه التي
تلتف حول الكعبه وتطوف وتطلب الله في
الدعام يعني مشاهد
في الحرم المكي بشكل يومي وكبير هنالك من
يقول انه للمره الاولى يشاهد الكعبه
وهنالك من يطلب الدعوات الخاصه
بتصوير الرسائل والصور لناس قد توفاهم
الله من عائلته ومواقف انسانيه كبيره جدا
شكرا جزيلا لك سلطان حدثنا من مكه المكرمه
الى صوره اليوم من درست غرب فرنسا
الاحتجاجات من كل الاتجاهات هذه المره
ليست للمعترضين على قانون التقاعد وانما
لصيادين تجمعوا في عده موانئ في البلاد
احتجاجا على لوائح الاتحاد الاوروبي
الخاصه بالصيد البحري ورساله واضحه
سنتظاهر حتى الموت
اما تصريح اليوم فهو لي وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابق مايك كومبيو حيث قال لا
اعلم ما الذي يتحدث عنه
كان يسخر من حديث ترامب حول الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه حيث سئل عن تصريح رئيس السابق
الذي قال ان حل هذا النزاع امر سهل للغايه
وانه يمكنه فعل ذلك في غضون يوم لكن
بالطريقه الخاصه به هو كان وزيرا للخارجيه
في عهد ترامب لكنه ليس الاول في اداره
الرئيس السابق الذي يخرج لينتقد تصريحاته
وافعاله كل حلفائك باعوك والان الخبر
العاجل ايضا عن تراب
تقول انه المراه التي يحقق بشان علاقتها
مع ترامب هي عارضه ازياء تدعى كريم
ماكدوغل
فيديو اليوم من اليابان رجل سقط وسقطت معه
نقوله في احد المطارات فقام جميع من حوله
بمساعدته وجمع النقود له كما نشاهد في
الفيديو
وذلك يظهر التعاون والامانه عند
اليابانيين ويفسر بعضا من اسباب النهضه
التي عاشتها البلاد على مدى العقود
الماضيه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا بموضوع
المراه التي تتحدث عنها
تقول بانه مدعي عامه يحقق في شراء ترامب
صمت امراه ثانيه كان على علاقه معها وهي
كريم
الان الى الزميل صهيب واخبار الساعه مساء
الخير مساء الخير راويه طبعا عارضه
الازياء اذا تضاف الى
الممثله ايضا التي اشترى ترامب صمتها
لاقامتها علاقه معها خارج اطار الزواج
سنرى ستؤول اليه الامور كذلك سنتابع الملف
كذلك الموقف يتطور في فرنسا تجدد
الاحتجاجات هناك على رفع سن التقاعد سنكون
مع مرافرين بعد قليل من باريس